leslie bonjour alors concrètement quels
sont les changements en vigueur est bien
le principal changement c'est que les
personnes vaccinées n'ont plus besoin de
faire un test pcr pour entrer en espagne
alors jusqu'à présent présenté un
résultat de test pcr négatif et est
obligatoire pour tout le monde c'est
donc une grande nouveauté
alors le gouvernement a précisé que les
voyageurs doivent avoir reçu leur
deuxième dose au minimum 14 jours avant
le déplacement et il faut avoir reçue
d'un des vaccins validé par l' agence
européenne du médicament
il s'agit donc de fighter moderna
astrazeneca ou jantzen l'espagne accepte
également deux vaccins chinois il s'agit
de sinopharm ici novak corona vac alors
cet allègement ne s'applique pas à tous
les pays du monde
les personnes vaccinées pourront rentrer
en espagne sans test uniquement celles
viennent de l'union européenne ou d'un
pays qui est sur liste verte alors les
personnes non vaccinées de plus de 6 ans
sont toujours dans l'obligation de
présenter un résultat de test pcr
négatifs ont un résultat de test
antigénique c'est la deuxième grande
nouveauté et les documents on le
rappelle sont acceptés en français pour
l'heure les slits pour faciliter
l'entrée en espagne le pays met déjà en
place le certificat européen exactement
car si c'est la date du 1er juillet qui
a été annoncé sur l'union européenne
l'espagne le met en place dès maintenant
alors ce passeport sanitaire doit
contenir plusieurs informations si la
personne est vacciné non s'est elle a
effectué un test pcr ou antigénique
avant son voyage
les dates et types de vaccins et de
tests effectués et c'est le passager a
eu la qu'ovide alors il peut être sous
format papier digital et doit contenir
en code barre ou un qr code afin de
pouvoir vérifier son authenticité
alors l'entrée en vigueur du passeport
sanitaire en espagne permet de réaliser
un premier essai pilote en europe et le
pays espère ainsi faciliter les
déplacements et attirer rapidement les
touristes merci beaucoup leslie pour ces
précisions leslie singla en direct de
barcelone